we have proved many properties and we've
made many constructions sometimes you
get given a particular diagram and you
have to make an adjustment in
construction you don't know where if you
have no other guesses to where to go
my suggestion is what is the most
important point in a circle the most
important point is the center right
learn chuckling yeah the center is very
useful in not every single instance but
a vast majority of them because once you
know where the center is you can relate
threats are really bad during the center
so it's really hard when you're close is
that that Oh how's that feel the wrong
way it sounds like I'm moving like a
painting like a little left they don't
do the right how's that you happier yeah
okay once you know where the center is
you have a whole lot of equal intervals
because everything from the center to
the circumference is equal that's really
useful so I'll give you one one minute
now that I've told you the center is an
important spot I'm not even going to
tell you what to join up to it and then
see what you can come up with I
suggested that the center would be a
helpful thing to put on here because
once you have the center you have all
kinds of isosceles triangles a lot of
things that are equal but then I didn't
tell you what things to join up to the
center okay now remember you're trying
to get between this angle and this angle
that's that's the transfer you trying to
make okay now remember I mentioned to
you that the angle at the circumference
you know a few things about in
particular you know some things in
relation to the angle the center
standing on the same arc do you remember
that so what I'm going to do is here's
the angle the circumference standing on
your arc here let's construct this guy
here is the angle at the center that's
standing on the same arc now you know
there ought to be a specific
relationship between those so just kind
of file that in the back you might and
let's see how we go first things first
after the construction is that when
you've got things and you want to talk
about them you need some labels right so
what would you like me to call this
angle down here
okay I can give it like full-on
coordinates and everything I can label
every single point but for now before I
do my formal proof I'm just trying to
map this out in my head I'm going to
give it a baby simply name like say
theta
how about theta that'll do okay
I'll give it I'll give everything I'll
then all the vertices after when I'm
constructing a full-proof okay now if
that's leader remember angle theta
matches up to a tangent right we don't
know too many things about tangent we're
going to learn a few more today as you
can see from the shape what do you know
about tangents right now what kinds of
things do you know changes are
perpendicular perpendicular to what to
the radius right line from the origin to
there not just anywhere to the point of
contact very good so this angle I'll
mark it in here over here is a right
angle do you agree so you're a right
angle you've got fear in there what's
this little angle left behind it's going
to be the cosmos and a theta right so
I'm going to mark that in ninety degrees
minus theta okay
now this is clearly progress at least
for the fact that I've gotten my angle
from the outside of the circle or sort
of on the outside sort of the inside and
definitely inside I mean in this sort of
triangle business in here that's a good
sign
okay now we joined outlines from the
center so we join a radii which means
that those radii are equal so I have and
isosceles triangle they're equal angles
are obviously two equal sides you see
that so over here up in this corner I'm
going to have also 90 degrees minus
theta okay you've got two angles in a
triangle once you've got to you've got
all the angles so what's the last one up
here now just to be sure right because I
know where we're going to go the angles
here add up to 180 degrees
you've got 180 here in the 1990 all you
need is a third angle that will come
for this - theater and - theater do you
agree so in order to get them to cancel
out that's what gives you tooth meter
yes and now we're there because of
course the angle at the center is is is
the elephant's double double the aim of
this conference standing on the key
marks so that's why you can get there
alright so that's that's charming isn't
it that's really nice I don't know who
discovered this excuse me but it's a
it's a beautiful little piece of
geometry which sort of really carefully
and nicely combined into a lot of the
other properties in a very elegant way
that we already know so how do we wear
this thing I'm going to give you a long
wedding and I'm going to give you a
short wedding okay because this is one
of the very longest properties that are
there it's number ten I think it is
first let's um let's just label
something so you've got this line over
here you've got this tangent right after
the teaching we drew a chord now it's
not just an E chord the chords related
to the teacher in fact it's attached to
the tangent it starts from the point of
contact and then it goes somewhere else
so being it is a chord at the point of
contact we give a special name we call
it the chord of contact this phrase is
important we're going to come back to it
a little bit later on when we go into
parabolas and when we learn this topic
called locus which is coming a little
bit later so the court of contact what
is it it's a caught any chord that's in
contact with a tangent
excuse me whichever tangent you
interested in catch it called a contact
thirdly remember we said that chord it
divided up our circle into two segments
right well this angle over here is the
angle in the segment on this side not
the segment on that side
the other one right so we have a word in
math or actually generally speaking when
you say not not your one but the other
one it starts with an A
we call it the alternate
right it's like when you when you go to
a banquet or something like that and
they're serving your dishes they
alternate as they go around
they're like beef chicken label they
give every second person something else
right so this just means the other one
so it's the alternate segment okay so
these are all of the features that you
need to know it's a few new words
they're few new phrases so therefore I'm
going to hijack this sheet and give you
the actual wording that I think is most
succinct to give you the full wording
and then I'll give you an even shorter
one which is one of a few times an
abbreviation interceptive okay so we're
doing number 10 if you want to fill this
in so it says the angle between the
tangents and can you feel in the next
bit it's between the tangent and arc
between the quarter contact right the
cord or contacts right is equal to the
angle or just equals and the green one
what's that angle where is it it's the
angle in the alternate segment so yeah
that's that's a mouthful right so this
is one of those reasons is really rare
times where I want you to if you have
another caller highlight or underline
this last phrase here and that's what
you can make your heading
this is often just called the angle in
the alternate segment yes
send it again so in all the properties
that I've mentioned so far I'll give you
a full wording and that's what you can
see on your on your page and pretty much
in all those cases use the full wording
and that's why I've provided to you
however this may be this may be the only
one actually where you can literally
just say this part is pipe down here and
people know what you're talking about
you don't actually need to mention
everything there but I'm making a big
deal about it because pretty much all
the other ones there's even a property
that's longer than this and have a look
at number six things not great but it's
actually quite easy fit 1414 I'm you'll
see we're going to learn this in periods
three and four today it's got six blanks
six blanks and every single one of them
is a distinct and big word it's not like
there are conjunctions or anything I
have very few of them that was really
long and there's no shortcut on that one
you have to put all six of those key
words are literate with the key words
right the key word here is angle and
alternate segment and then we know what
you're talking about pretty much